I feel that there have been a large number of fairly well-qualified, or exceptionally well-qualified
people who have seen objects that have not had any really logical explanation other than
this.
I think that maybe in fact each and every one of them does have an explanation, but I think
that there are so many possibilities, so many thousands of possibilities of other planets
out somewhere in the universe that would have a livable atmosphere that I would hate
to rule out.
The possibility that maybe there are people or some type of human life on some of these.
And if this is the case, then it's not too unfeasible to think that perhaps some of
these objects might have been something of this time.
You don't think that the comparatively short step out into space that the Mercury flight
will take you on is far enough out to make any observations in this area.
No, I think we're still at a fairly low order of getting out into space when you regard
when you speak of space and being millions of miles involved, and we're only getting out a hundred
miles or so.
What about the so-called plan effect?
The snowflakes, the fireflies, both the Sharon Carpenter seem to feel that it's frost
or some nature off of the capsule, but apparently Glenn still sort of cast doubt on that theory.